المترجم: Bayan Baroudi
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
1,750,000 طفلاً حُرموا من التعليم.
1,350,000 طفلاً مهددون بخطر
الانقطاع عن التعليم.
مدرسة واحدة من أصل 3 مدارس
إما تهدمت أو تضررت أو امتلأت بالنازحين.
حتى النظام التعليمي فقد 150 ألف
موظف في مجال التعليم.
أرقام كبيرة ومخيفة،
ومازالت تزداد، حتى في هذه
اللحظة هي في ازدياد مستمر.
وتتحول هذه الأرقام إلى إحصائيات كبيرة
تتحول إلى كرة ثلجية كبيرة تتضخم
بمرور الوقت، ويجب إيقافها بأية طريقة
مع أن الأرقام كبيرة، لكن الأمل كبير
قبل الأزمة، كنا كسوريين نعتبر
التعليم أولوية
كالأكل والشرب
ومع بداية الأزمة، وتوزيع السلال الغذائية،
كان المعلمون يشكلون مبادرات طوعية
لإنقاذ الأطفال من الضياع
كنا نشعر بالألم عند رؤية الأطفال
يتركون المدرسة ولا يلتحقون بالتعليم
كنا نشعر بالعجز عند رؤية
المدارس تعجّ بالنازحين
ولا تؤدي دورها في التعليم
في عام 2012، قررت مع مجموعة
من صديقاتي أن نفعل شيئاً
دخلنا المدارس التي تأوي العائلات
وطرقنا أبوابهم، باباً تلو
الباب، وغرفةً غرفة لنسألهم:
"هل من أطفال يحبون التعلم لديكم؟"
تفاعل الأهالي جداً معنا
أعطونا أسماء أولادهم
لنسجلها في القوائم
ونقسمهم إلى مجموعات كي تأخذ
كل معلمةٍ منا مجموعة لها
بدأنا بتعليم الأطفال
أصعب سؤال كان يواجهني:
"أين سنعلمهم؟"
تخيلوا معي، كل المدارس
ملأى بالأسر النازحة
كل المدارس
الصفوف، القاعات، المخابر
حتى غرف الإدارة
كان سؤالاً صعباً جداً
مع ذلك لم نتوقف
وكنا نبحث عن أي مكان فارغ لنعلمهم
علمناهم على الأدراج وفي الممرات
في الباحات، وحتى غرف الأهالي
كنا ندخل إلى غرف الأهالي
ونعلّم الأطفال في زاوية الغرفة
وكان الأهالي يراقبوننا
أثناء تدريس أطفالهم
وانتقلنا من مدرسة لمدرسة،
من حيٍّ لحيّ
وتوسعنا كثيراً
كنا مستمتعين جداً
مستمتعين لدرجة أن نفرح
لرؤية طفلٍ يتابع معنا ويكمل
وأكبر فرحة كانت عند علمنا
بهذا الطفل أنه التحق بالمدرسة
مع ذلك، وبالرغم من وجود
أهلٍ يهتمون بالتعليم،
للأسف يوجد نقيضهم لا يدركون
أهمية التعليم أبداً
لا أنسى مرةً حين طرقنا باب
إحدى العائلات
وسألناهم إذا يرغبون بتعليم أولادهم
رد الأب بكل بساطة:
"لا يوجد لدي أطفال يرغبون بالتعليم،
أولادي سيعملون"
لا أنسى نظرة الحزن في عيون أولاده
من المؤكد أنهم كانوا يرغبون
بالتعلّم كرفاقهم
شعرنا بالعجز
لكن رغم ذلك لا يمكننا لومه
لا يمكننا لوم الأب نهائياً
ربما يكون خائفاً على أطفاله
من ظروف البلد
وربما لا يستطيع تقديم
لقمة العيش لأولاده
وليس بمقدوره تأمين
مستلزمات التعليم لهم
لا يمكننا لومه
صحيحٌ ذلك، لكن لا يمكن
للتعليم أن يكون حلماً لأي طفل
فالتعليم حقٌّ لكل طفل
مبادرتنا التي قمنا بها
لم تكن الوحيدة
وكان هناك مبادرات كثيرة
في كل أنحاء سوريا
في المدن والأرياف، حتى في المخيمات
تعاون الجميع، وهذا ما يميزنا
نحن كسوريين
لم نستكن أبداً
تعاون الجميع، أفراداً وجمعيات
ومنظمات غير حكومية
الكلُّ تعاون، وكان لدينا أمل
المبادرة التي قمنا بها كانت حلاً
لكنها للأسف حل بسيط
والواقع يفرض علينا حلاً أكبر
نريد حلاً أكبر للأطفال
الذين تركوا المدرسة منذ عدة سنوات
ثم التحقوا بعد ذلك بالمدرسة
من هؤلاء الأطفال كانت راوية؛
راوية طفلة، كانت في مرحلة الروضة
حين بدأت معها قصة النزوح
من مكانٍ لمكان، منطقة لمنطقة
سنةً تلو السنة
إلى أن أصبح عمرها 9 سنوات
حين ذلك، قرر أهلها أن يسجلوها في المدرسة
ولم تستطع الالتحاق بالصف الذي
يناسب عمرها
واضطرت إدارة المدرسة أن تسجلها
في الصف الذي يناسب معلوماتها
فسجلوها في الصف ذي المنهج فئة B
وأخذت معلومات الصف الأول كاملةً
والتي كانت تنقصها، وذلك خلال
الفصل الدراسي الأول
ومعلومات الفصل الثاني كاملةً
في الفصل الدراسي الثاني
ضغط كبير بالمعلومات نعم،
لكن المعلمين استطاعوا تعويض
الكثير من المعلومات التي نقصتها
برغم حب راوية للتعليم والمدرسة كثيراً،
لكن كان من الصعب عليها الدخول إلى
مدرسة فيها أطفال ليسوا بعمرها
مع ذلك، فهي تدرس وأهلها يساعدونها
وتنتظر انتهاء تعليمها في المنهج B
كي تلتحق بالصف الذي يناسب عمرها
استطاعت راوية العودة إلى المدرسة
وأطفال كثر مثلها استطاعوا
بعد قصة نزوح طويلة
لكن للأسف كان هناك أطفال
لم يستطيعوا العودة نهائياً
رفيف طفلةٌ بعمر 14 سنة
لم تستطع العودة إلى المدرسة نهائياً
لأن المدرسة المجاورة لمنزلها مهدَّمة
والمدرسة الصالحة للتعليم بعيدة
عن منزلها
كان الطريق طويلاً جداً ومخيفاً
وزاد خوفها حين خُطفت
لمدة 10 أيام
وبعدها عادت فبقيت في المنزل من جديد
لكن حظ رفيف جميل جداً
حيث التقت بمعلمات قريبات
من مسكنها
وبفضلهن - المعلمات في منطقتها -
استطاعت تعويض القليل
من المعلومات التي فاتتها
التقيت بها في الأسبوع الماضي
قالت لي وبكل إصرار:
"أنا أدرس بجدّ كثيراً،
وأصر على نيل الشهادة الإعدادية"
وأنا واثقة بأنها ستنالها
لأن الطريق الطويل لم يكن
عائقاً أبداً في وجهها
الطريق الطويل الذي منعها
من الذهاب إلى المدرسة،
منع أطفالاً كثر من الذهاب أيضاً
لكنا نستطيع مساعدتهم كي يذهبوا
لذلك نجعل الطريق الطويل أقصر
كيف؟
عندما نزرع الرغبة في التعلم
في نفوس أطفالنا
عندما ننشر شكل التعليم الذاتي
عندما يستطيع الطالب تعليم نفسه
بنفسه وبأسهل الطرق
منهج التعليم الذاتي موجود ومبسط
لكن يجب المساهمة في نشره
كيف؟
تخيلوا معي
لو فرضنا 100 معلم
وكل معلم يقدم ساعةً طوعيةً
واحدةً فقط في الأسبوع
ساعة طوعية واحدة فقط
على مدار السنة ومن 100 معلم،
يصبح لدينا حوالي 5000 ساعة طوعية
من 100 معلم فقط!
كيف إذن لو كانو أكثر من ذلك!
من المؤكد سيكون لدينا ساعات
طوعية أكبر بكثير
لأن فيها خدمة لأطفالنا في البلد
ليس صعباً أبداً
ساعة طوعية واحدة من وقتك
ليست صعبة
- وأخاطب المعلمين هنا -
ساعة طوعية واحدة يمكن أن
تنقذ فيها إنساناً يرغب بالتعلم
وبحاجة إلى من يقف بجانبه
في بداية الطريق
على كل حال، المبادرات والحلول التي تمت
سواءً مبادرات أو حلول فردية،
أو منهج B أو منهج تعليم ذاتي،
يتم تطبيقها في كل سوريا
ومازلنا في انتظار تطبيق
أشياء جديدة أكثر
لأن أطفالنا بحاجة أكثر
وهذا ما نتحدث عنه في المنصة فنحن
بحاجة لحلول أكثر وأكثر
في النهاية أقول:
عندما تحاولون معرفة ما يخبؤه
المستقبل لبلدنا
لا تتابعوا النشرات الإخبارية
ولا تبحثوا في فنجان القهوة
ولا تنظروا إلى كلام المنجمين
يكفي أن تنظروا في عيون أطفالنا
وتروا كم قدمنا من التعليم لهم
لأنه مهما تقفلت أبواب واقعنا اليوم،
مفتاح واحد يفتحها
هو مفتاح التعليم
مفتاح التعليم هذا مستقبل أطفالنا
ومستقبلنا جميعاً
شكراً
(تصفيق)